ghosts hot on camera hopefully we can
convince you that these are fake and
official effects are at play
and you can hold my hand if you want to
[Music]
i'll be honest this one's pretty good
what is a ghost nico have you ever seen
a ghost or had a ghostly premonition no
i don't believe in ghosts all of my
experiences can be 100 explained with
science i actually haven't either i
totally have not i know that people out
there when they have an experience like
this they swear by it so while we don't
have that emotional connection to these
clips we do have a few years of vfx
experience under our belt hopefully we
can convince you that these are fake
as visual effects artists we can analyze
the pixels figure out if we are looking
at real ghost footage and if visual
effects are at play we're not going to
get into arguments about what happens
after you die or anything like that
leave that up to the frothy comment
section down below so some of these
videos have like 20 million views i'm
just imagining the person who watches
like one or two ghost videos and then
the youtube algorithm's just like you
like ghosts
wall of ghost videos it's about to
happen to you after seeing this video
sorry
oh goodness oh goodness what do we have
here ghosts caught on camera
all right
okay so the ghost is wrecking the place
so first off okay it's a ghost so a
ghost is a person you have to pick up
the spoon and ghostly throw it you don't
go like but you don't like spider ghost
spider web to a spoon and then yank it
across the room that's what it seems
like this is like ghost spider-man who
wants a spoon
okay so obviously option a ghosts are
real the end option
i b
a pretty good feeling we're just looking
at some strings pulling stuff all right
now we have a lot of focus on this
drawer it's one of the drawers that's
quite well framed in the shot not any of
the other drawers in the kitchen exactly
but also think about this too now if
you're gonna tug on that with a string
you only have two locations you can do
it you don't want to contaminate the
space by standing in the room creating
unnecessary like shadow or something
like that so you're either hiding behind
that door or you're off frame right
around the camera not a frame right
around the camera just so happens to be
the direction that most of these objects
are traveling
the door that opens also follows the
same logic there's probably a dude sorry
there's a dude
[Laughter]
around frame right and he's got two
little strings some fishing lines
something small and one's attached to
the handle of the drawer the other one
is already attached to the silverware
inside it i can't see any evidence of
visual effects but this would be so
easily faked that you have to go with
the more plausible explanation
their whole tick tock is uh ghost
related by the way so really here's the
question is the influencer
ben and laney or is it the ghost i mean
is the ghost getting a cut
[Laughter]
[Music]
i like that one that's just some guy
vaping out of his car window
i'll be honest this one's pretty good
but look out there's some smoke on the
front left bumper too see i don't think
it's smoke
if it's smoke it's not dissipating the
way smoke should
the little flicker of white at the
bottom corner of the screen on the car's
bumper it feels like something really
close to the lens is out of focus well
it's a crappy like uh infrared sensor
too so you might get some sort of
streaking or trails i do not see
evidence of visual effects here yeah
could we remake this effect yeah we
totally could like this is something you
could do in visual effects and you can
have it be flawless and be hard to see
how it's made but the other thing is
like would a vfx artist think to just
put a random little blob down by the
car's bumper no they probably wouldn't
you know that kind of stuff is very
accidental oh you know i think i figured
out what it is it could this could be
like a porch or something like that it
could have something above it and
somebody could have just
stomped on the ground a little bit of
dust from up in the rafters and just
floated by and it's only like a few feet
away from the camera so you have dust
coming off the left too
oh you're right oh you got it you got it
you got it i got it you got it i got it
all right moving on
it's funny like once you like get it and
you see it you're like oh that's it you
just know
[Music]
this is just
low shutter speed it's a low shutter
speed on an infrared sensor look at the
particles streaking so this is the
trailing effect i'm talking about you
see like dust streaking across the lens
here if you look at footage of old video
cameras it happens all the time with hot
spots as well either we're dealing with
trailing artifacts on the infrared
sensor or a low shutter speed but not
just like having a little shutter but
having a shutter that's kind of like
averaging or putting together these long
exposures yeah most cameras take a frame
24 times a second or 30 times a second
but sometimes you need so much light
that you can only capture a frame say
once every half second or once every
second something like the background
which isn't moving will appear really
solid but the person who's moving is
basically just turning into a big motion
blur as they keep going across the
reason he's disappearing over there is
because the only reason he's being
illuminated is because the camera itself
is pushing out infrared light into the
space for it to pick up for the sensor
itself to detect and once you start
getting that far away you're leaving
that natural area of where the infrared
light is because look how bright
everything is
whoa interesting his camera's getting
screwed up that's a cool like data mosh
effect going on okay i wonder if this is
just the codec glitching out and
not updating parts of the image uh as a
person walks through it so the parts
that say static basically the computer
goes okay i'm just gonna give you a
picture now you just hold this picture
until i tell you that something there's
new data there and that's basically how
it saves space in terms of compressing
the video so like the house the tree
everything around here is not moving
it's basically just a still picture
that's been told to stay on the frame
for as long as possible
and so as this person gets close
it could be glitching out and keeping
some of that there and not updating it
with new information because it's dark
and just have one tiny little moving
thing on screen
it could be that it's just too little
movement to trigger the codec to create
a new keyframe basically to add new data
to it or to add new data to that block
what you're about to witness on this
video can only be described as an
assault
these two fine gentlemen were minding
their own business in the stairwell when
they were brutally assaulted by a ghost
he then endures a very brief but very
aggressive session of some paranormal
ground and pound
all right so visual effects we finally
have some visual effects this one's
really straightforward
it's pretty clearly
a locked off camera
the guys go and they do one their first
pass and their friend goes and does the
second pass as the ghost and they just
literally literally layer the footage on
top
and make it transparent and then run all
this through the crappiest
most degrading color grade and color
filters and smudge and blur and all that
stuff
this is a useless security camera this
is actually what it looks like no one
would ever put a security camera in a
stairwell like this that has zero light
and can't get you an image
[Music]
that ghost imagine being that ghost
though and your unfinished business was
kicking the out of that guy
there's one guy i gotta mountain deliver
a paranormal grounded pound to
so yes i finally kicked kevin's ass
the following clip was filmed while my
mom and i were on vacation we decided to
leave our cats home alone for the few
nights we would be gone
jesus christ
oh that cat oh this is this is creepy
the mirror adds a nice cinematic touch
oh there's a second
cat and you can hold my hand if you want
to
[Music]
okay
all right so the first thing that jumps
out to me is this being fake if you look
closely at the table when it shakes you
can see that it's been composited in
because you can see it fade in and out
over the background footage so they've
filmed that separately and then stuck it
on top of the footage that they have
there so the vfx they're basically
debunked this whole shot but let's let's
take a look at the rest of it and see
what else stands out as evidence of this
being faked so the shadow in the hallway
based on the reflection the light
casting that shadow is on the ground
around the corner so somebody set up a
light on the floor and you know most
people don't put their lights on the
floors also the door gets pulled shut in
the same spot from where the person was
casting the shadow how convenient that
the things that get moved get pulled
towards where the people would be
the camera getting knocked off the shelf
is unique i would assume that somebody
else is in this room with a string one
of the things they don't show you the
end of the shot like if the camera kept
recording it was pointing at the wall
why not continue the shot until it
points to the wall yeah in fact it's
more likely the camera fell off the
shelf
and then it felt and then there's like a
dude
at the table i was like oh yeah i guess
we'll cut this part
secondly the cat that comes around the
corner and looks at us happens to look
in the direction
of where the table was shaken in other
words if there's a person hiding this
room calling the cat they would have to
be below the camera in order to shake
the table call the cat who happens to
look in this direction and then pull a
string or whatever to knock the camera
down the cat's motion on the left really
implies that there's a person
by the table slash camera see look at
that cat look at the person on the floor
looking at the camera a little bit
ears twitch your ears twitching your
switch back up yeah yeah the cat gave us
a
clue
so even though this is a fake clip i
still actually really like it you know
stage or not the uh the cat acting
cacting is really well done
that was a pent up scream from all these
scares the only way i can keep a clear
head is if i let the tiny screams out
occasionally
[Music]
a door has opened
let's see if something else moves now
that's usually how it goes i feel like i
feel like we're going to get a locker
slam
[Music]
yeah
that convenient window there it's like
it's only mysterious if people like us
can't just look at it and go oh yeah
there's a window there where someone
could easily reach through and wiggle
that thing
come on ghost spooky face is it gonna be
the slippery side
yeah
wow that ghoster has some good dramatic
timing yeah the ghost slipped
no that was the ghost of slipping
i can't believe this person got 20
million views of this video what are we
doing that's a professional youtuber for
over a decade
when i see a video like this that gets
20 million views and i think about how
much work can put into our videos
sometimes sometimes it's tough that's
the real scary moral of this situation
[Music]
this is probably a real camera that they
just stuck up on like a ladder
yeah actually pause
you can see an actual security camera it
looks like exactly
[Laughter]
and you can see how high they are
mounting these cameras
so just that alone right there kind of
puts this one to bed this camera is
really at the height of picture frames
this camera is as high
as this
it's like have you ever seen a security
camera mounted at like just above head
level yeah just someone's just someone
back there slamming a door there's
literally a window right there which
provides a perfect
entry point to push on that locker and
then strings bro we can talk about
strings all day but strings are great
you can do a lot with strings like
you're out there like i need a really
good computer to do visual effects like
no just literally black black thread
like when i watch the stuff i'm like
i'm not even trying to analyze it for
vfx i'm just going i'm trying to put
myself in the shoes
of a ghost it's like i'm a ghost i go to
school i'm like
slam
shake
randomly open a door some stuff falls
out it's like what are you doing
then he slips on the floor
like are ghosts just drunk
i want to help recreate what a ghost
does when it goes into a house it's just
like
just like yeah i'm a ghost
[Music]
like what are you doing just bumping
into crap
[Laughter]
all right so after we recorded this
video
i heard some really weird noises from
this hallway maybe somebody's just
playing a prank on us but i grabbed my
sound recorder let's go in there see
what we can discover okay
oh
i'm hearing something hold on i got turn
it up
oh great spirits if you are there
make yourself known
i've really been enjoying cordon
digital.com
no ads
early access to exclusive videos son of
a dungeon is freaking awesome
oh great spirits who do not rest in
peace why are you so agitated
crew cuts season two is dropping and i
will not rest until i see it
huh
wow oh great spirits what treasures lion
wait for us
fifteen percent off on march live
hangouts with the crew
all the corridor videos you know and
love are even better
i i think the scene was coming from this
room all right let's go let's check it
out
good digital.com
ghosts it's most likely a string
ghosts are made out of string i learned
that most ghost videos are actually just
videos of objects the ghosts move
i was hoping for like more videos of
like you know a girl in a colonial dress
like floating through the air or
something like that
but no there's actually very little
footage of actual ghosts the little
smoke puff
that senses tiny chill down the spine
yes so halloween comes around every year
in fact and so for next year we need
some good ghost videos please leave a
comment below of what you think the most
convincing ghost footage is so we can
look at it alright guys happy halloween
have a safe time trick or treating don't
be afraid of ghosts if you spot any
ghosts this halloween night don't be
afraid just look around the corner find
your buddy with the string give him a
high five